Stakes are higher and I'm just excited
because I had a big part in my boy James
you know after it was revealed that gal
gadot's Wonder Woman 3 is no longer
moving forward it seems new reports
suggest that Jason momoa's time as
Arthur Curry AKA Aquaman and the DC EU
is potentially coming to an end when
Aquaman and the lost kingdom hits
theaters in December 2023 however it's
being reported that mamoy is being
considered for a new DC character the
Bounty Hunter Lobo which isn't that
ironic considering Lobo and Aquaman have
fought in the comics after new DC
Studios execs James Gunn and Peter
saffron have taken over the pair are
said to discuss their future plans with
Warner Brothers as to how they plan to
grow out the dceu multiple reports State
this includes undoing the Schneider
verse that Zack Snyder put together with
the duo aiming to focus on other DC
characters like Lobo when I caught up
with Momoa the actor certainly expressed
his excitement for the future of the
dceu all while teasing something big to
come I think with Peter Safran and uh Mr
Gunn at the helm now of DC I'm very
excited about that there's a lot of
there's a lot of cool things going to be
coming up and uh one of my dreams come
true will be happening on under their
watch so stay tuned
[Music]